remember when those pesky other branches
of government wouldn't bow down to
Obama's whim and the president famously
bragged about going it alone I've got a
pair and I've got a song and I could use
that pin to sign executive orders
wherever and whenever I can take steps
without legislation to expand
opportunity for more American families
that's what I'm going to do now Obama's
out and it will soon be Donald Trump
wielding his pen and phone
here are five scary powers that
President Trump will inherit from Obama
I'm going to bomb the [ __ ] out of them
for the past eight years I've worked to
put the fight against terrorism on a
firmer legal foot during the Libya
intervention Obama decided that he
didn't need Congress to approve massive
bombing campaigns and regime change came
he saw he died Obama has done legal
gymnastics to justify using the same
authorization that george w bush got to
fight al Qaeda and the Taliban ascends
our armed forces to places like West
Africa Somalia Yemen and Syria
not to mention staying in Pakistan and
Afghanistan and going back to Iraq all
without Congress so if the Mexicans
won't pay for his wall president Trump
might just as well decide to bomb them
with the terrorists you have to take out
their families Obama made up his own
rules on targeted killing denying that
courts could review his kill list and
only paying lip service to drone
guidelines when he thought Mitt Romney
might win in 2012 that never actually
happened and even in his last month in
office Obama has continued to expand the
reach of our flying robots and special
operations forces so President Trump can
now vaporize any person he puts on his
kilis even American citizens even
outside of acknowledged battlefields
even if civilians died all without due
process boycott Apple until they give
that Security number
Obama expanded the powers of secret
courts that provide little more than a
rubber stamp for mass surveillance of
American he supports weakening
encryption general warrants that cover
millions of people and a host of powers
with the ultimate goal of giving scoops
for the NSA has called Total Information
Awareness
access here every words move purchase
and relationship all without your
knowledge
Orwell would have been impressed and
Trump certainly will be I'm going to
open up our libel laws the leader of the
self-anointed most transparent
administration in history has prosecuted
more whistleblowers under the Espionage
Act and all other presidents in history
put together there are there's
classified and then there's classified
if the administration exploded the
number of classified documents and
fought the ACLU and New York Times in
court to keep it legal interpretation
secret oh and Obama's Justice Department
spied on journalists and investigated
them as co-conspirators they tried to
drag man to an espionage investigation
based on what Trump thinks of the media
reporter should take care not to violate
any secret laws going forward especially
in secret drone zone they're bringing
crime they're rapists are you an
immigrant was brought here illegally as
a child and who trusted Obama with your
personal information in exchange for his
promise not to deport you bad news early
first off he's deported more people than
any president in history so that should
have been a red flag as you were saying
you always have the legal authority to
stop deportation then why he did 40
million people wherever they are not
working we'll take you you know that you
left other anytime in horrors that were
deported on you called me before the
people after Congress did enact an
immigration Obama turned to his pen and
phone again but he overreached and his
executive order giving deportation
relief was ruled unconstitutional I'm
beginning a new effort to fix as much of
our immigration system as I can on my
own so now he'll be gone but you'll
still be listed in a homeland security
database Obama
at least you won't have to worry about
being served up to President Trump on a
silver platter he prefers gold so next
time you find yourself applauding the
president for doing a gleeful and run
around the Constitution and the
separation of powers yes we did yes we
can pause for a moment and ask yourself
what will happen when it's president
Kanye West I have to decide it in 2020
to run for president thanks Obama
[Music]